quelle aubaine in peace
images ont été filmées par ba dinh kader
un des milliers de migrants qui sont
toujours massés au bélarus à la
frontière de la pologne l'homme
originaire du kurdistan irakien espère
ainsi être entendus par l'union
européenne
nous espérons je ne suis pas inquiet
pour moi même mais je suis inquiet pour
tous les enfants ils souffrent du froid
vous savez le problème c'est qu'ils ne
peuvent plus tenir on peut tenir encore
un peu mais pas plus que jusqu'à l'un
des enfants comme ce jeune garçon dont
les prothèses sont maintenant brisé une
raconte bazine ou encore ceux là qui
dorment à ciel ouvert pour la plupart
cela ne fait pas tellement de différence
dit-il si on a un sac de couchage ou pas
vous savez ça ne protège pas de la neige
ou de la pluie
la croix rouge du bélarus distribuer de
l'eau un peu de nourriture et du bois
pour lutter contre le froid mais rien
qu'une chance vraiment les conditions
catastrophiques dans lesquels attendent
tous ces gens
les soldats leur bloquent la route mais
derrière eu des polonais sont prêtes à
les aider dit badine
ils ne sont qu'à deux kilomètres de nous
dit badine j'aimerais qu'ils puissent
nous apporter à manger qu'ils puissent
tous nous apporter mais les soldats ne
les laisse pas s'approcher de la
frontière les polonais sont gentils ces
polonais si proche et si loin à la fois
dont par le bas à dean se sont pour la
plupart de simples citoyens engagés mais
qui se sentent de plus en plus démunis
les histoires des enfants jetés à
travers la part belle est le
les fausses couches que le migrant vu de
bons dont la forêt
il y a
il ya des histoires horribles qu'on
entend
il accuse le gouvernement polonais
d'enfreindre de façon systématique le
droit international et les conventions
de genève la sécurité du pays à ne
consiste pas à bloquer l'aide
humanitaire et de boulot que est de
suspendre le fonctionnement de la
convention de genève ces personnes ont
le droit de porter demande d'asile en
pologne
si la pologne peut tuer parce que c'est
bien de tuer des migrants dont on parle
nous avons déjà des morts après tout
peut-être qu'après ce sera acceptée de
tuer des femmes ou des membres de la
communauté lgbt dit kalina il n'y a pas
de limites
surtout et 1 le ministre de l'intérieur
polonais s'est inquiétée de ce qu'il
appelle une provocation dangereuse du
bélarus en faisant circuler la fausse
rumeur que la pologne est sur le point
d'ouvrir sa frontière et que l'allemagne
va dépêcher des autocars pour venir
chercher les migrants la pologne a
riposté en envoyant des milliers de sms
au téléphone cellulaire près de la
frontière en dénonçant un mensonge total
est un non sens la pologne continuera de
protéger sa frontière dit le message
je ne veux pas voir des gens mourir je
ne pourrais pas le supporter 10 badine
je ne pourrais pas
malgré sa peur d'une escalade de la
violence et celle du froid qui finira
vite par les achever dit badine il ne
compte pas abandonner pas plus que ses
compagnons d'infortuné
ici marie ève bédard radio canada près
de kunitz à la pologne